the jurogan experience we were talking
before this uh podcast started that you
when you left opium anthony you went and
decided to do your own thing
behind a pay wall yeah so you're you're
like
in this position you're sort of
uncancelable there's you don't have
all the trappings that everybody else
has in terms of like sponsors
yeah coming after you you just have
subscribers
yeah this was uh a conscious decision
because uh
i saw it coming a while ago the uh what
they call
cancel cultures well you guys get hit
with it
first out of all the people that i've
ever heard of because
when you guys had that homeless person
on who said he wanted a
what do you say you want to rape
condoleezza rice condoleezza rice and
the queen of england
the first lady i i gotta i gotta say
something about that though we had just
gotten to satellite radio
from fm radio and to us this was like
all right it opens up a whole new world
of what we can do
so i thought what what better place to
just showcase a homeless person
let's see what rantings and ramblings
come out of a homeless person's mind
so bring them up in the studio put them
in front of a mic and let him go off
it's satellite no fcc rules and regs and
the guy starts talking about crazy stuff
and
and raping political figures and uh
the queen of england and we think it's
hilarious
because you're getting that insight
you're getting into the mind of a crazy
homeless guy on the street
and the [ __ ] hits the fan oh my god
condoleezza rice that brings the sex
thing in
and the race thing and all that and they
lost their mind and we were like
oh [ __ ] we're getting fired again like
we're gonna get fired for this
what happened you didn't get fired but
you guys got suspended
for yeah for how long we got suspended
for
uh i think it was a month i think that
was a month suspension
from satellite radio but we were still
at k rock in new york
doing that show in the morning because
we used to do both yeah we used to go
across with the microphone yeah that
with you guys we did the
walk over terrestrial and then we would
we would broadcast
live as we were walking down new york
city with mike's
comics so we would go to the other
studio yeah we would do things
occasionally like rich voss would go
into a diner or something and just start
doing stand up
yes in front of the customers hilarious
cringe stand up
cringe stand up these people don't know
what's happening and
stupid big club soda kenny would
announce some
ladies and gentlemen they're looking
like they're you know it's gonna be like
a mass shooting is gonna start
and uh it was hilarious you guys were
the birth
of podcasts it was a podcast
on the radio yeah we didn't know it at
the time we didn't know what nobody knew
what a podcast
was but it was a bunch of guys that you
find funny you like hanging out with
talking about anything and that seems to
be what the formula is yeah
you guys figured it out first because
every other radio show that i did like
if i did stern
or anything else you did it was very
formatted
regimented yeah like he had some things
you want to talk you wanted to talk to
me about fear factor you want to talk to
me about the ufc
i had questions about this and you know
it's always
like and then you have a call-in and
then you have celebrity guests and
he he had it all like very smooth
you guys would just bring a bunch of
people in yeah and then patrice would
start talking and burr would start
talking
ari would start talking it was just
chaos dude and we were all
just having fun just having fun yeah
when you have a room of those guys
nick depaolo and patrice god rest his
soul
and bill burr norton uh all
these guys colin quinn they're all in a
room
you can't lose like like as
people will hear it and say holy [ __ ]
that was one of the funniest shows
and it's like what show theopian anthony
show so people remember the name
of the show yeah but all these other
guys are delivering this amazing funny
comedy
uh so it worked that way and we we
embraced that and just started bringing
these comics uh
back on in different combinations
because you know
better than anyone some of the funniest
stuff you'll ever hear
are guys [ __ ] on each other yeah and
and when someone was in we called it
being in the barrel
you know and that could consist of
wearing a shirt you come in wearing a
shirt
and patrice goes what the [ __ ] what kind
of shirt is that you wear
where the [ __ ] you get and now
everyone's on your shirt
now you're sitting there going you're
looking at all the comics going
what can i use to get this off me so
you'd have to [ __ ] on
voss's teeth or you know always so
so it was this constant battle to get
the [ __ ] off of you yeah and it was
funny
every [ __ ] time and you guys were so
great at letting the comics just
go wild and yeah put any restrictions on
anybody
and not try to control the conversation
just let it have fun just let it breathe
a lot of shows a lot of hosts and this
is something you do
that is fantastic and rare in the
business
let your guests talk let them and if you
have a guest a room full of guests
let them have fun if if you hear funny
[ __ ] going on
a lot of people their ego gets in the
way yeah and they feel hey it's my show
my name's on the marquee i have to
jump in and say something if something
funny's happening
back off leave it the [ __ ] alone it's
it's gonna be great people are gonna
love it and they're gonna go
oh that was on the opium show so it
doesn't really matter who's saying it
yeah you guys had figured it out it
really is the birth of podcast and i i
learned a lot
from doing that show and i also learned
that i wanted to do it
because i yeah when i would do your show
i was like god i want to do a show like
this
i want to do something like this because
it was it was you know when i did
regular radio if i did on tour i would
say oh that may be fun to do a regular
radio show but then i would be like
they will never hire me i will say
something stupid i'll get fired this is
not going to work out for me but i do
your show and i believe uh huh
i believe this is this i can i think i
think
i think i could do this i was paranoid
because i never went to school for radio
i was in construction for until my early
to mid 30s dude
i got into radio late and my impression
was always
if i didn't know the alloy of the metal
in the transmitter antenna
there's no way you're getting into radio
like i thought you had to know all this
[ __ ] that they taught you in
radio school and the fact of the matter
was these
jocks were constantly looking for
somebody that was entertaining
yeah you never realize i never realized
how how
uh desperate a lot of these jocks are
for somebody
that could make people laugh uh and
someone with zlatan
interest too someone was interesting who
can talk about different things talk
about a lot of different things you know
sometimes you gotta talk out your ass
like you almost kind of know what it's
about
for sure but this this the other thing
about like what you guys did
was you created a safe place
for men like where you could just be a
[ __ ] idiot one of the last bastions
that's the thing it's like there's a lot
of men out there
but there's not a lot of entertainment
that's geared towards men
and one of the things that comes up on
my podcast when
the advertising people get to talk and
they're like jesus christ he's got like
94
men like what is going on here this is
crazy i'm like
they're not represented they're not men
are not represented
it's like i don't know what the number
is of regular television but it's not
geared towards men no not at all it's
there's some
there's like the talk and the view and
there's a lot of these shows that are
geared towards women
but it turns like a man show you can't
have
um like a male oriented show on network
television it would be toxic
it's a personal affront to feminism and
women and regardless it's just men being
men
i don't know it's weird right i don't
know where this idea came from that
in the past even couple of decades which
you know relative to uh a tortoise or a
mayfly
you know it it varies how long a period
of time that is
but in that period of time we as humans
were supposed to have
physically and mentally evolved to this
point where men don't still want to talk
about
tits and cars and lifestyle stuff and
bash each other guns of course like we i
i think there are people that actually
think we we have evolved out of that
you know what instead of being
brainwashed a lot of men that are
hand-packed
and they work in some terrible job where
human resources is breathing down their
neck
and they have neutered themselves and
they put themselves in this position
of like this sort of like non-man
and yes non-man yeah and then because of
that
they they chastise other free men like
look at this this is toxic masculinity
in its finest form
they say all these crazy things like you
can't be you're not free it doesn't
and it's also equated somehow or another
with cruelty
with being a bad person yeah being a
shitty person
just by joking around or doing the
things that we like to talk
talking about the things that we like to
talk about yeah yep uh i hear
punching down a lot is a bad thing that
was your whole show
yeah that was the entire show the entire
20-year history of the opening anthony
show
there was never a punch that got past
the
180 degree you guys don't get enough
credit i really i really say i say it
every time i can that you
were the inspiration for podcasts
without a doubt
it really is for what i i think for what
howard did
for the the shock jock genre in radio
we kind of were right at that precipice
of of
radio and podcast yeah when when that
happened
and i think what we were doing was
better suited to a podcast than it was a
radio show yeah
i think so too but it was a great radio
show yeah but it was a great radio show
the problem is the suits yeah the
problem was not the kind
the problem was the suits the problems
people go hey hey you can't
this is not like meanwhile did you just
see what happened everyone was crying
laughing
that's entertainment yeah that's what
they want yeah
it got to a point where early on
even when i got in which was again late
in the game but early on in the 80s and
90s
all they gave a [ __ ] about were ratings
if you had ratings
and you did something stupid you'd get
this
uh slap on the wrist in public and
behind the door with the gm and the pd
and all the other management people
they'd be like oh my god that was great
great job
oh look take off a week paid we'll say
you're suspended and that's it
they really did this and we we went
through a few of those and
and it turned into they really did get
mad
and they really started suspending you
without pay and
firing you and these were these suits
like you say
that just didn't understand the talent
end of the business anymore
and when radio stations were owned by
uh mom and pop operations we we were at
waaf
up in uh massachusetts and it was owned
by zappos
communications i met zappos i met the
guy
uh when we went to infinity broadcasting
there was no mr infinity
there was mel karmazin and there was all
the suits from cbs
cbs has affiliates and they also deal
in laundry detergent with this
subsidiary and like
you say something and baby diapers don't
sell
like that's how when it got really
[ __ ] up
and personalities weren't able to do
what they do anymore because
now you're [ __ ] up their sales in the
burger industry and
you know zappos owned a [ __ ] radio
station yeah
and he loved when his radio station got
ratings
that was all there was to it now it's
all a conglomerate of [ __ ]
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience